で 今日は何でしょうか
法句経の説明の日でございます
第2章に入りましたけどね
アッパマーダという箇所ですね
励みということですね
21番目はこういう風な偈なんです
アッパマードーアマタパダン
パマードーマッチュノーパダン
アッパマッターナミーヤンティ
イエパマッターヤターマター
アッパマードーアマタパダン
パマードーマッチュノーパダン
アッパマッターナミーヤンティ
イエパマッターヤターマター
一応カタカナで書いてないので
発音は聞いて見るしかないんです
なんで変わるんですか
いや マターなんで  マターなかったっけ
アッパマードーアマタパダン
パマードーマッチュノーパダン
アッパマッターナミーヤンティ
イエパマッターヤターマター
すごい これもそんなにね
信じがたい 分かり難い
大変な難しいということではございませんし
アッパマードーという言葉は
一応キーワードとしてその偈で使ってるんですね
次の言葉 アマタパダン
アマタっていうのは不死というね
死なないという意味で
そのパダン 言葉であると
それからパマードー パマーで放逸することは
マッチュノーパダン マッチュっていうのは死ぬこと
死の こちら道であると書いてましたけど
言葉である 道であるということで
アッパマッターナミーヤンティ
それで不放逸の人々は死ぬことはありません
イエパマッターヤターマター
パマッと放逸でいる人々は
死んだと同じことだと
どちらがするんですか
それで 22番目 エータンヴィセーサトーニャッッター
アッパマーダンミパンビカー
アッパマッテパモーダンティ
アリアナンゴーチェレーラター
エータンヴィセーサトーニャッッター
ヴィセーサトーというのは特徴
この不放逸に対する 不放逸っていうのはなんかちょっと変な言葉だよということでね
これ不死ということだからね
それ知ってパンディタ
賢者たちはアッパマーダンミ
この不放逸になることに
アッパマッテパモーダンティ
大変喜びを感じる 喜ぶ
やっぱり不放逸はありがたいことだと喜ぶんですね
それで聖者の生き方 聖者のアリアナンゴーチェレーというのは聖者たちの境地ですね
本当は聖者の境地なんですけど
私は生き方としましたけどね
聖者の境地をまた喜ぶということで楽しむということで日本訳されてますけど
こちらでは聖者の生き方に就けると
そんな意味はそうそう変わったってもね
別に 気にすることはないと思います
それで二三番目 テジャイノサティティカーニッチャンダッラパラッカマー
なんか変な文字がすっちょ入ります
プサンティディーラニッバーナಂヨガッケーマンアヌッテラン
テジャイノサティティカーニッチャンダッラパラッカマー
テーというのはカレーラということで
この賢者たち この頭の良い人々は
サーティティカーっていうのはもう決断
切断することなく 辞めることなく
もうかなり頑張っているということでね
ジャイノ 瞑想すると 実践すると
修行すると テジャイノサーティティカー
言葉通りにすればそういうことで
ニッチャンダッラパラッカマー
間に何かエンマー書いてますけどね
それは勝手に入るもので
こちらは知りません ですから
エンマークをないということにして読んでみてください
ダッラっていうのはかなり強くということで
パラッカマーっていうのはこのもう勇者のようにすごい頑張ってみるというね
なかなか滅多なことでめげない
もうやりすぎる もうすごい
もう頑張るということで
ダッラっていうのは強く
そういう風に このよくものすごく頑張って
決して負けないで 決してめげることなく修行する
それでこの三行目ね 三行目
こちらディーラ ディーラっていうのは賢者
頭の良い人っていうことで
このテーっていうのはこの人々につなげるんですね
テーカレーラっていうのは
このディーラ 頭の良い人々は
この賢者たちはニッバーナンプサンティ
ニッバーナン涅槃をプサンティっていうのは体験する
はっきりと体験 プサンティというのは触れるという意味の言葉なんですね
触れるということは 仏教でこの認識するときよく使う言葉で
例えば目に情報触れると見えるという
耳に音が触れると聞くというんですよ
それで心に やっぱり涅槃もそのように触れるんです
だから体験するんです
彼は涅槃を体験する 涅槃っていうのはヨガッケーマンというんですね
これ涅槃の特色 形容詞ですけど
これの意味はちょっとややこしいんですけど
ケーマンっていうのは大変安らぎ
ということで ヨーガっていうのは修行なんですけど
修行の安らぎであるという訳もできますけど
いわゆる修行することで頑張ることの安らぎ
でも 注釈書では伝統的な解釈ではヨーガは束縛で訳-- 解釈してあって
人々はすべての生命は束縛されていて
そこからの解放 安らぎと
ということで ということ
そういう涅槃を体験すると
アヌッタランというのは涅槃より上のものはないんですね
この上のは この上ないということでアヌッタラ
で この上ないというのはすごい日本語はなんか簡単みたいな感じしますけど
まあ漢字としてはね 無常と言えばね
やっぱりこのパーリ語
サンスクリット語になってくると
アヌッタランというのはかなり力強い言葉なんですね
最高というね まあ本当に最高という
ただ単に最高というわけでもないんです
いわゆる文字通りに最尚
とても優れている 最高
この上のないということで涅槃なんですね
で 一応簡単に理解してほしいんだから
そういう風な簡単な訳をしてみたんです
えーと それで この 二十一
二十二  二十三という この偈三つセットになっている
えーと この中で キーワードとして言っているのは
このアッパマーダという言葉なんですね
このアッパマーダ不放逸というなんですけど
このなんか日本訳しているところでいろいろ訳してあって
怠ることないとかね 怠けることではありませんとかね
なぜならば 不放逸というのは
あの 日常の日本語ではありません
で 私もあまりこの漢字調べてないんだから
あの漢文の意味って何なのかって
あまり今の時点では調べたことはないんだからわかりません
しかし 仏教用語として不放逸という言葉を使っているんですね
アッパマーダには それで
不放逸はわかりませんよというと
怠ることないという風に
また柔らかい日本語にする
怠るって何なのかわからない
まあ怠けることではないとまた柔らかくしてあげる
怠けないことであると
それで現代の方々は怠けないことかと一応理解する
それでみんなこちらでこの怠けることを言ってるんだと
なんだ そんなことかと
ということで あまり面白がらないんですよ
しかし また真剣に考えてみると
怠けることに対して いわゆる怠けないことに対して
そんな大胆なことを言うんでしょうかと
言えるんでしょうかと
で これでこのこちらで書いてるんだからね
例えば不放逸は不死の道であると
そちらに不放逸ところに怠けないことと入れ替えてみてください
怠けないことは不死の道であると
というと そこまで言えるのかという疑問がね
出てくるんですよ そこまではいらんでしょうに
怠けないことはね 素晴らしいことであるとかね
怠けない人はもうかなり人生は成功するんだぞとかね
怠けない人は自分の目的に達するんだぞとかね
それぐらいはもう一応言うのは普通なのに
怠けないことは不死であると言うと
やっぱりあの 当然みんな疑問
何よこれと疑問が考えて生まれてくるんですね
その疑問がなぜ生まれるかというと
この日本語の言葉に あの
粘りすぎたからなんですけど
これは日本の方々は日本語で考えるのはしょうがないしね
でも怠けるということは
突然ある日現れた言葉ではないんですね
[咳]もともとは不放逸という言葉がありまして
で これの不放逸の意味って何ですかね
不放逸ですね  漢字の意味って
手放して逸脱してしまうこと
不が  出さないっていうことですね
自分から手放しちゃって
解放させちゃって 逸脱っていうのはその場所から逃げる意味
で それが負ですから ないという意味だから
そういうことがないってことが
うんうん なるほど まあそういう
日本語はそういう感じ
勝手気ままに生きないっていう
勝手気ままにならないっていう
好きなようなことしない
今おっしゃった意味で考えると
不放逸はそういう意味なんですけど
もう現代日本語としてはそうそっちを使う言葉ではないんだから
まあもっとよく使える言葉にしましょうということで
次の順番で使った言葉は何でしたっけ
怠ることなくという まあ怠るといったって
もっと柔らかい言葉がないんでしょうかというところで
怠けるということになったんですね
怠けることはないと それで怠けるといえば
誰のでも日常的な単語ですから
考える時はその言葉で考えちゃうんですよ
これかなりこの なんていうの
進化して 進化というか退化というかね
この元の言葉はかなり翻訳
翻訳で退化して退化して
自分にわかる言葉に怠けるという言葉で止まっちゃったんだから
それはちょっと忘れてしまっちゃって
怠けるという言葉で考えてみる
怠けないこと 死なないことであると
あれ これは何なのかと
そこまで言うのかということになってしまう
それで怠けることについて
怠けないことについて
もう もう厳密に考えてみる
それで最近の質問もありまして
そういう風に真剣に真面目に
やっぱり意味を理解したいんだと
怠けないことは死なないことであると言ったら
これは何なのかと理解したいでしょうし
真面目に怠けないということはどういうことですかと
朝から晩まで必死で仕事をすること
何かやってることですかと
あるいはもう何でもいいんだから
もうやることには徹底的に夢中になって必死でやることですかとかね
という風なもう疑問が出てきて
もしかするとそうなるはずでもないと
そんなもう誰でもそれはそんなにいいとは思わないでしょうね
朝から晩まで一瞬たりとも暇がなく
必死に必死な勢いでもうあれやこれやとやってるんだったら
なんか戦争状態の生き方でしょうね
戦争 戦争状態の生き方っていうのは
そんなありがたい生き方とはあんま全然思えないんですよ
それが不死なる境地と言ってくれると
さらに困るということになるんですね
そういうことで 怠けないという
これが意味が考えなくてはいけないんですね
そういうことで このアッパマーダという言葉の意味は何なのかと
でも 仏教の世界ではかすかにでも疑いあった言葉ではないんです
仏教の世界ではもう分かりきった言葉なんですね
このアッパマーダ 不放逸というのは
それがわからないと もう恥ずかしくてたまらんというように
[笑い]で まあそれぐらい当たり前の言葉なんです
それで注釈書でタッタアッパマードーティ
パダン タッタっていうのはここで
アッパマードーティっていうのはこの
ここでアッパマーダというパダン
言葉はマハンタン ものすごい大きいという意味なんですね
巨大という意味なんですね
大きな巨大なアッタン
意味意義をディーペティ
示してるんだと させてるんだと
すごい巨大な意味をさせてるんだと
マハンタン 巨大なアッタン意味をガヘットは用いて取って使ってティッタティ
ティッタティっていうのは立っているという意味なんですけど
このアッパマーダという言葉が巨大な意味を入っているものであると
言葉っていうのは器にしちゃうと
器の中に何か意味という中身が入ってるんですね
その意味で二行目書いてるんです
だからあの巨大な意味を入ってるんだと
この一つの言葉の中で
それでさらに説明する
サカランっていうのはすべて
全部 サカランピヒ 強調します
すべてのテーピタカン
三蔵経 仏典 仏教は全部三蔵経にしているんだからね
で 三蔵経ですね で 三蔵経であるブッダワチャナン
ブッダの言葉 三蔵経に入っているすべてのブッダの言葉をアハリットは
まあ参照して用いて使って
カティーヤマーナン カティーヤかもしれませんだけど
カティーヤマーナン 喋っても説法してもということなんです
だから三蔵経をすべて参考にして三蔵経をすべて参考にして喋ってみてもアッパマーダパダンエーワオータラティ
結局はアッパマーダというパダン
言葉の中に入ってしまいますよ
それは注釈書の意味なんですね
この すべての三蔵経に参照して参考にして
ずーっと説法したっても
全部一言葉の中に入りますよと
アッパマーダという だから仏教であるこの一番大きい言葉なんです
その中に全部入り込んでしまいます
だからこのことをわからないと言うと
もうもうありとはしないんですよ
仏教の人々は ちょっとこれはわからないと
普通仏教の世界ではアッパマーダということをわからないという人はいません
別にわかってるわけではないんだけど
本気で 一応誤解したりとかね
迷ったりって それはないんです
それはすごい言葉ですよというぐらいででも終わっちゃうんです
ただ単純に怠けるということにはしないんです
このフォイスフォイス
怠ける怠けないではないんですよ
なぜならば 怠けるという言葉にパーリ語で別な言葉があるんです
アラシアンという アラソー
アラシアン パーリ語で怠けるという言葉はこのアラシアンですよ
アラシアン 怠け者にはアラソーと言うんです
怠け者 アラソー アラシアンというのは怠け
ですからこの なんとなく日本語でこれ怠けに変身してしまったんですけど
怠けには別な単語があるんです
そういうわけで このアッパマーダは怠けないという意味でもない
パマーダは怠けるという意味でもないんですね
もっとすごい深い意味
仏教は全部入っている
もう巨大な器なんですね
それでこの日本語で怠けということになって
すごい勘違いしましたかというと
まあそうとも言えないんですよ
なぜかというと 大体パーリ語にしたっても
そのニュアンスはないわけじゃないんです
怠けるというニュアンスがパマーダの中に
ないわけじゃないんです
だからもうパーリ語を使って仏教を勉強している
こういう仏教の人々でも
まあそっちを滑ってしまう可能性はあります
これは怠けることであると
そうやってそちらに滑ってしまう
この小さな意味に でも本当はその小さな意味ではなくて
すごい包括的な巨大な意味なんです
そこでアッパマーダについて
この次のパーリの言葉
これはお釈迦様の言葉
セイヤターピ ビッキャウェーヤーニカーニチャ ジャングラーナンパーナーナン パダージャーターニ サッバー
ニターニ ハッティパデ サモーダーナン ガッチャンティ ハッティパダン テサン アッガマッカーヨティ ヤディダン マハンタッテナー
マハンタッテナー エーワ メーワ コー ビッキャウェーヤーニ カーニチャ ジャングラーナン パーナーナン
パーナーナンというこの言葉は生命のこと
生き物のこと 生き物のこと
その中でジャングラーナン パーナーナン
ジャングラっていうのは歩くっていうことなんですね
歩く生き物の中で この場合は大体陸上なんですね
陸上で歩く生き物の中で
ジャングラーナン 生き物のパーダージャーターニ
パダージャーターニ パダっていうのは足
足の種類ですね ジャータっていうのは
いろんな種類の足があるでしょうと
この陸上で歩いているすべての生き物の
あらゆる足があるんではないかと
そのすべての足 足はサッバーニ
そのすべてがサッバーニターニ
ハッティパデ 象の足の中
ハッティパデ 中にサモーダーナン ガッチャンティ
入ってしまいますよと
この陸上であらゆる動物がいますよと
歩く動物は ヘビは入りませんですけどね
足も歩くということではないしね
ですから ジャングラっていうのは足で歩く動物っていう意味になります
その中でどんな形の足がいくらあっても
どんな足でも象の足の中には入ります
この足跡の中に 何のことなく入ります
人間の足も何のことなくゾウの足の中に入ります
納めます ハッティパダンテーサンアッガマッカイル
そこでハッティパダン
ゾウの足はテーサン その足の中でアッガンアッカエティ
最高だと言いますよと
トップだと言いますよと
アッガンというのはトップというぐらい
最高という意味でもないんですね
一番ということで ヤディダン
何のポイントでトップですかというと
マハンタッテーナ 大きさで
大きさでゾウの足跡はトップなんですね
エワメワコビッカヴェ
このように比丘たちよ
イエーケーチクサラダンマ
クサラダンマっていうのはクサラダンマ
善法と訳しますけど 善
良いという いわゆる一切の道徳的なこと
道徳と良いと言える何かがあるならば
サッベーテ すべてアッパマーダ
アッパマーダという言葉の中にアッパマーダムーラカ
アッパマーダは基準にしていますよと
根元はアッパマーダだよと
アッパマーダサモーサラナ
すべてアッパマーダの中に入ってしまいますよ
それをお釈迦様の言葉なんです
世の中で善たるものっていうのは
あるならば何でもいいんだから
どちらにしたってもアッパマーダの中に入りますよと
いわゆるアッパマーダほどすごいことはないんだよということなんです
アッパマーダをテーサンダンマーナン
その善なる法の中で 全ての中でアッパマーダがアッガンアッカエティ
トップであると 最高なものであるということなんですね
訳はそういう それ 私はさっさと勝手に入れた訳で
もうたった二 三分で別に考えることも何もしないで
で ビクライよ 陸上で歩くすべての生き物の足跡はゾウの足跡の中に入ります
ゾウの足跡の中に収めます
そのように何か善たることがあるとするならば
それらすべてが不放逸の中に入ります
不放逸に収めますということで
これはまあ  人間がないんですよね
どちらに？ ゾウの字が
これだと  あ そうですか
人間のゾウとか  まあ出たもの感じを出してやったんですけど
ゾウには人間がないんですね
なんでないんですかね
人間じゃないから  か 人間より頭がいいか
どちらかで まあ大体まあこれぐらいでアッパマーダっていうのはもうとてつもない言葉であるということはわかると思います
それでお釈迦様のこのすごいこの特徴というか
お釈迦様のすごく優れているところっていうのは
このすごい一般的な言葉を使って
もう絶対的な真理を語る
このわけもわからないことっていうのをもう全くもう教えません
単語を使うときも 用語を使うときも
そこら辺にそこら辺にある単語で全部語るんですよ
それは究極的な智慧がないと
このすごい柔らかい簡単な言葉で物事を語れるっていうことはできないんです
難しいことをペラペラペラペラ言う人っていうのは
それほど能力あるってわけじゃないんです
自分でインスピレーションないし
自分で理解してるわけじゃないんですね
ただ覚えてるものはそのままもうおんぶ返しするだけで
ですから このすごい頭のいい人と悪い人を選ぶ方法
2つは喋ってることはとても簡単単純かないかということなんです
喋ってることはとても簡単単純でわかりやすいんだったら
その人は結構鋭いんです
言ってることは自分で理解しているんです
それで聞いてる人も大体問題なく
ああそうですかと理解するんです
それで私が一番頭が悪いということになってるんです
なぜならば ここまで何年も喋ってるのにほとんどわかってないって
で そう簡単単純では理解してくれないならば
言ってる人は何者かということになります
それではこのアッパマーダという不放逸っていうのは
では怠けることではないとわかったとする
では何なのかと 何でも放棄して逃げ回ることではありませんという意味ですから
それ何なのかと で それからもうスライドというやつはないんですから
ギリギリの十一時半で作り始めたんだから
[笑い]これ結構時間かかりますよ
これ作るには それでも像に人偏が入るはいろいろ
まあいろいろありますし
このアッパマーダという言葉は
このもともとマッドという言葉から作ってるんですよ
この長いこちらマーダありますね
これは名詞にするときはそうなってますけど
これAは短くしてマッドなんですけど A
も取っちゃうとマッドになります
それは英語でいうマッドではなくて
まあ同じですけど 意味は
なぜならば同じ言語系列だから
英語でもマッドといえばもう狂ってるという頭がおかしいって意味なんですね
それマッドというサンスクリット語なんです
で マッドはサンスクリット語だったらマッドと読むんです
ダという濁音なんです
濁音じゃないかな ダですね
ダ日本語でもありますね
ディはないんですね 日本語でダというのはないんですね
それでマッドということは
このそのままローマ字するとマッドになっちゃうし
それでマッドといえばマッドネスというマッドというクレイジーということになるんですね
意味としては 頭がおかしいと
狂っていると そこでそこから現代語から考えてみましょう
マッドといえば何なのかね
頭がおかしいという人は
狂ってる人っていうのは
別に怠け者ですかね 怠け者というわけじゃないんですよ
狂ってるんです ただそれだけ
だから結局はやりすぎということは必ずあるんですね
マッドという状態の人々の場合は
何やるかわからない もう管理不可能
操縦不可能な人間ですよ
狂ってるといえば 大変ですよ
いわゆる暴走するんですね
だからだいたいみんなえらい気をつけるんですね
人が頭がおかしくなると狂っちゃうと
だから面白いことに このパマーダのあるいはマッドという
これから使ってる言葉なんです
それでマッドっていうのは頭がおかしいって意味なんです
英語のマッドでなくても
サンスクリット語でも頭がおかしいって意味なんです
いわゆる酔っている 狂っているという
その酔う状態に酔い状態にこのあまりにも入り込んでいる場合は PA
のこれはパーリ語でPAなんですが
サンスクリット語になるとPRAなんですね PRA
なんですね そのPRAはサンスクリット語
パーリ語になっちゃうと
補っちゃうんです もう一つPで
だからP 2つになっちゃうんです
[音楽]aは否定形で
否定形a取っちゃうとこれ発音できんだからまた取っちゃうんです
ですからパマーダという言葉とアッパマーダという言葉にはなります
間はいくつか書かなくちゃいけないんですけど
書いてないんです で これでパマーダっていうのは頭がおかしい
おかしい状態になっている
狂ってる 酔ってるという意味なんですよ
もっと説明すると 状況を把握できない
状況判断できないという状態なんです
だから酔っ払った状態なんです
自分の周りの状況に対してはもう何一つも理解しようとはしない状態
パマーダ状態なんです
だからなんか怠けるということとは
なんか縁がなくなっちゃうんですね
それで何なのかというと
我々は狂っているならば
頭がおかしくなっているならば
私たちの状態は周り 今起こっている状態
今の環境においては全く気づかないんですね
だからおかしい 狂ってる人が何するかわからないんですよ
その場でやるべきことはやらないんですね
だから狂ってると言うんですよ
やるべきことをちゃんとやるんだったら
正常な普通な人でしょうし
挨拶するべき時は挨拶するはもうちゃんと喋るべき時は喋るならば
座るべき時は座る ならば別に狂ってるわけじゃないんです
そのやるべきことをやらない
それわからない だから狂ってる人だったら
こちらに一人がいるならば
突然踊り出すことも可能でしょうし
怒り出すことも可能でしょうし
服なんか全部脱がせちゃって
もう素っ裸になることも可能でしょうし
あるいはみんなに殴る可能性もあるし
何するかわからないんです
とにかくこの状況でやってやるべきことをやらないでやってはいけないことをやってしまう状態が狂ってる状態なんです
判断できない状態なんですね
そこで我々は今の状況でやるべきことをできない状態でいるならば
その人をやることは全て間違いでしょう
だから狂った人がやることは何のことなくまとめて間違いと言えます
踊ってはいけないのに踊っていると
行儀よく振る舞わなくちゃいけない
例えばこの場所だったら行儀よく振る舞わなくちゃいけないのに
ものすごい失礼な態度をとるとかね
例えばこちらで寝込んじゃって
もういびきかいて寝るということは
あまりかっこいいことでもないし
失礼なことでしょうし
まあ狂ってる人だったら別にへっちゃらで
もうそのまま寝てしまう可能性もあります
寝てもういびきかいて寝て寝る可能性もあります
何するかわからない とにかく狂った人とやることはなんだかんだでも間違いであるならば
間違いのことはすべて不善行為なんですね
正しい行為じゃないんです
それでお釈迦様の定義はわかると思います
アッパマーダっていうのは狂ってないということで
狂ってないということは正気で
今何が起きているかわかります
理解できます 今私はどこにいるかと理解できます
今私は何をやるべきかということは理解できます
その人は悪いことはしないです
だから すべての善という行為の大本はアッパマーダですよとこの経典でお釈迦様が教えてるんです
すべてアッパマーダにかかっている
物事を状況判断できるかないかということにかかってるんですね
そこで注釈書はもうこの注釈書でも何十何ページも渡ってこのエピソードを書いてますよ
あまりにも長くて長くて
もう読みだしちゃうと面白くて読めますけど
エピソードだから何ページですかね
[背景音楽]二十六ページまで行って十八
三十ページまで行くと
まあ一応小説一冊ぐらいは物語が書いてます
もっとあります いやまあ数えるの忘れちゃった
ありすぎて また別に二
三回に分けてこのストーリーを説明するしかないかも
それでですね 百六十ページから二百二十七ページまでストーリーなんです
何ページですかね 六十七ページ
六十七ページで この小さなローマ字で
またパーリ語で これ経典語ではないんだからパーリ語であろうとも
これに繰り返し文句はないんです
経典では繰り返し文句あるんですけど
だからこれ日本訳するとやっぱり本一冊になるんです
本一冊分書いているのはストーリーなんです
これで芸の説明には二ページで終わり
三ページで終わり 芸も三つあるのに
なんでかとわからないです
自分でも言ってるのに
これの注釈するためには三蔵経を全部説明したっても足らんぞと言って言いながら
もう二ページで まあ注釈を終わってるんです
これストーリーがいろいろストーリーがありますね
だからストーリーは別に独立して面白いんですよ
大体この学生さんはこのパーリ語を勉強したい場合は
このダンマパダだった方のダンマパダの注釈書を勉強するんですよ
それでストーリーだから中身も簡単し
これもう意味を調べながら調べながらストーリーを読むんですね
それを読んでみたら パーリ語っていうのは極簡単に身についてしまいます
それから直接読めるようになります
大学なんかでは なんとか選んで
この経典の一部とか なんとか選んでやりますから
博士になってもわからないんですね
パーリ語が パーリ語の博士かもしれませんだけど
まあわからないものといえばパーリ語ぐらいです
これで結構問題は起きますよ
なぜならば そういう方々の方が信頼するし
いい加減に書く私のものは信頼しないんです
でも いい加減に書く書くと書くところはかなり怖いんですよ
結構言ってます それからかなり研究して言っているんです
それで注釈書の意味に入りますけど
アッアッパマーダに今注釈それぐらいで説明していますよ
で ソー ソーパネーサアッタトサティヤ
ソーっていうのはアッパマーダというやつということなんです
これは  これはということで
これはもうなんというか
アッタト 意味としてはサティヤ
サティですよと サティヤアヴィッパワーソーナーマ
アヴィッパワーサっていうのは離れていない
サティと一緒に生活することをアヴィッパワーサなんですね
ワーサっていうのは生活すること
アヴィッパワーサっていうのは離れないということ
同居する サティと一緒に同居するという意味ですよ
アッパマーダっていうのは
これでまとめて定義終わり
もう注釈終わりっていうことになったんです
さらに同じことを繰り返します
ニッチャン いつもウパッティターヤサティヤ
ウパッティターヤっていうのはこの
ありますということで
サティヤ 常にサティがあって
という意味ですと ニッチャンウパッティターヤサティヤチェータンナーマ
チェータンっていうのは
チェータンっていうのはこれのナーマ
そういう ナーマというのは名前
意味ですよということで
だからアッパマーダっていうのはサティのこと
サティ サティっていうのは皆様方は瞑想する方々はよく知ってます
サティっていうのはこの
いつでも今の瞬間に目覚めている
今の瞬間はよく知っておく
今の瞬間何なのか それがいつでも我々は今の瞬間で生きている
過去の瞬間で生きているわけじゃないし
将来の瞬間で生きているわけでもないんです
で 今生きているんですね
だから間違いを犯すならば
今犯すんです 良いことをするならば
今しなくちゃいけないんです
失敗したくないと思う人は
今失敗しなきゃいいんです
何が起ころうしたっても
今起こるものなんですね
だから過去と言えば起こって終わったとも
終了して関係ないことになっているんだという意味で
将来といえば起こるかもしれませんという可能性だけで
必ず起こるということでもないんです
物事は いろんな道があるんだから
どうなるかわからないね
将来は 種を植えたんだから必ずしも花が咲くということはないんですね
将来は花が咲くかもしれません
しかし 花が咲くにもいろいろ原因
状況は必要なんですよ
そこで花が咲く寸前に状況が変わっちゃうと咲かなくなっちゃうんですね
咲く寸前でもわからないんですよ
状況が変わったら だからこの
例えば明日咲くそうと思ったところで
家の猫がそこで飛んで行っちゃったら
その上で これで壊れちゃうと
もう咲きませんからね
だから将来っていうのはいつでも不確定で
どうなるかわからない
過去はもう変えることも何もできん
終わったことで存在もしない
過去は 全く存在しないんです
ただ 我々の心の中で覚えているだけのことです
しかし この覚えているっていうことはまた過去じゃないんですよ
現在なんです  そこまで言う必要ないんだから
また簡単なところに戻りますけど
我々は実際は今の瞬間で生きている
失敗したしたというならば
それ今の瞬間で失敗したんです
だから失敗したくなければ
今の瞬間で失敗しない方でしないことでもう成り立つのです
悪いことをしたくないと思うならば
そんなに踏ん張る必要ないんですよ
今だけ悪いことをしなきゃいいんです
で いつでもそれだけのことで人生っていうのはうまくいけばいいんです
それ 今の瞬間に気づくということをサティと言うんです
だから苦しむことの全く反対なんです
ですからアッパマーダっていうのはサティの実践
まあサティの実践というのは
この皆様知っているヴィパッサナー瞑想ですね
だからヴィパッサナーそのものが全ての禅の大本なんです
大元で捕まってみれば
他の小さな小さな善なんかは全部もう引っ張ってきます
だからサティに混ざる善はないんです
象の足跡と同じ それより大きい足跡を持ってこようと思ったっても
これはまあ無理な話です
ありえないんです まあそれで意味が
まあそれぐらいの意味でしょうね
そこで原文にテキスト手元にあると思いますけど
アッパマーダアマタパダン
アッパマーダ この瞬間に気づいていることこそがアマタパダン
不死という道 言葉であると
そこでアマタパダンというこのスクリーンにあります
アマタ アマタパダン アマタングッチェティニッバーナ
アマタンというのはニッバーナ
涅槃である これ注釈書
ですからこの注釈書でまたからかって言うんですよ
人は病気にならない 年取らない
死なないという意味じゃないんだよと
そんなのはありませんと
人は病気になって死にますよと
だから不死と言ったっても
そんなものを言ってるわけじゃないんだと
というふうに注釈書で一応説明してありますけど
だから不死の道 不死の道というのは涅槃のこと
解脱のこと だから勘違いして欲しくないんだと
人は死なないんだよと
そんなのはありえない
ありえないことで 人のことを言ってるんじゃない
これ真理のことを言ってるんです
この肉体のことを言ってるわけじゃないんです
で まあひいて言えば心のことかもしれません
心が不死という涅槃という境地を体験してみる
体験してしまう それからはそれ以上やることがなくなっちゃうんです
それでこのパダンの意味なんですけど
次 下からアマタは涅槃
解脱です パダンでその方法を示す
アマタッサアディガムーパヨーティブッダン
その二行の二行目の意味
また下一つ書いてます
パダンティウパーヨーマッゴー
パダンティ パダンというのはウパーヨー
ウパーヨーっていうのは手段という意味なんですね
マッゴーって 道方法ですね
ということで なんか難しくなりました
で あの偈文見てください
アマタパダン アマタっていうのは涅槃
パダンっていうのは方法
涅槃への方法はアッパマーダである
いわゆる涅槃を経験したければ
解脱を経験したければ
サティの実践しなさいということなんです
もっと俗っぽく言えば
ヴィパッサナー実践しなさいよと
ヴィパッサナー実践って何なのか
すごい難しいことかと
いえ なんのことない 今の瞬間に気づいておく
そこで智慧が現れる だって一番大きなものを取っちゃったんだから
それから小さな小さなものは繋げてくるんだから
道連れに だから必要な
例えば怠け者だったら怠けがなくなる
私は怠け者で困ったな困ったなと思ってる人でも
試しにヴィパッサナーをちょっと実践してみてください
たちまち怠けが消えてしまうんです
私はすぐ疲れるんだとかね
そういうあらゆる精神的な
ほとんど精神的な病気なんです
体力がない 体力がないと堂々と言う人というのは
かなり体格があって 筋肉ムリムリで
よく平気で言うんですね
自分はちょっと体力がないんだからとかね
だからみんな精神的な異常で病気なんですよ
ですから それは別にどうったことはなく
これを置いておいてサティを実践してみる
そうすると そんなものはいとも簡単に過ぎていきます
体力ないないと泣いている人にとっては
これは頭の問題だからね
それ治ります 対人関係は良くないんだけど
なんとか瞑想でもしたらそれが直せます
それ私すごく気が悪くなっちゃうんで
そんなこと言われると
そんなくだらんことにやるもんじゃないんだよと
それは放っておいて 真剣真面目にサティの実践しなさいと
いろんな文句ごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ言ってはいけませんと
対人関係はできんとかね
人と一緒にいるとすごい緊張するんだそうとかね
仕事には自信がないんだそうとかね
そんなもうちっぽけな
もうどうにもすごいつまらないことに足引っ張られて
偉大なる人間の命というのはもうゴミにしちゃうんですね
だから死ぬまでゴミのごとくではなくて
ゴミそのもので生きていて死んでしまっちゃうんです
だからそれは解決してあげるということじゃないんです
仏教は もっとすごいことをやってあげようとしているんです
だからもう わかりやすい例えで言えば
100円ちょうだいとかね
もう何かもうもうもう食べてないんだから 100円だけでもいいんだからちょうだいと言った人に
ではあなたにもう  1億円あげますよ
言うとそれ断ると そんなのでご飯食べられませんと
なんであんた不親切ではないかと
私はこの飢えているんではない
それでたった 100円でしょ
私は欲しいというのは
それぐらい何のこともないんではないかと文句言うんですかね
相手がもうわかりました
100円はあげません
その代わりに 1億円あげますと
ブッダがそれを言ってるんです
対人関係はうまくいってないんだと言っても
こちらいえ これは置いておいてくださいと
であんたはこのサティを実践しなさいと言ったら
すごい もう私もそういうことを言われて
私も機嫌が悪くなっちゃうし
それを置いておいてサティ実践しないと向こうも機嫌が悪くなるんですね
それで物別れでいつでも終わっちゃうんです
北朝鮮と国際会議やってるような感じなんです
絶対相手言うことは理解してやんそうっていう
それで会議が成り立ち方
だからその問題はいつでもあることなんです
何かほんの小さな もうもうもう考える価値もない小さなことで足が引っ張られて
それでぶーぶー文句言いながらこういうところに来て
私はそんなのはどうでもいいんだからいい加減これやってみなさいよと
これやってみると そんなのはあらっという間
あっという間にもうたちまち消えてしまうんですよ
それよりすごい巨大な生きる目的
自分にはもう成立しているんですよ
もう怠ける暇がなくなっちゃうんです
体力がないんだ すぐ疲れるんだ
そんな言う暇もなくなっちゃうんですよ
全て揃ってきます だからブッダの道っていうのは究極的な答えを出してあげるぞと
幸福といえば あんた幸福になるだったら究極的な幸福をあげますと
あんた考える幸福はあげませんと
だから円以上だったら億円あげますよと
それからその人がご飯食べようか
土地買おうが家買おうが
もう何でも買ってでいいでしょうに
円でね まあ賞味期限切れてるないならばもうまあおにぎりも買えないしね
まあそれでも買えませんですけど
円で買えるものはないんですから
今は で それでその人が怒ってもね
あんたは不親切やなんとかと言っても
億円もらっちゃえばすぐその場で
その人は想像してもなかったほどの幸せになるでしょうに
そういうわけでサティを実践するということで
一切の問題が解決する
生きている生きるものにある一切の苦しみがそれで消える
だからそれ以上やることはなくなっちゃうんですね
それで終了ということになるんですね
それが一言でまとめてお釈迦様がアッパマーダという言葉にしているんです
だからなんでお釈迦様が涅槃に入った時
亡くなった時も 最後の最後の言葉として残したのもアッパマーデーナサンパーデータ
アッパマーダで頑張りなさいと
いわゆるサンパーデータというのは実践するアッパマーダを実践しなさい
それで亡くなったんです
だからこれが仏教そのものなんです
それでアッパマーダと涅槃の関係って何でしょうかというと
この使い方によってアッパマーダは道
涅槃は結果 いつでもミャンマーのお坊さんたちでも道可涅槃とかよくよく使っている言葉があります
道可涅槃で道可涅槃とわからなくなっちゃいますけど
で 私はそういう あの あのセット言葉っていうのはセットフレーズは使わないんだから使えないんです
道と可というのはパーリ語の直訳なんです
道はマッガで 可はパラと言うんですね
アビダンマではマッガパラマッガパラマッガパラと言うんですね
だから我々にとってはマッガパラニッバーナというのは結構感動的なセットフレーズなんですよ
シンハラ語でも シンハラ語になるとちょっとサンスクリットっぽくなっちゃいますから
マーガ・パラ・ニルバーナとなるんです
サンスクリット語になっちゃうんです
そう言うと信者さんはすごい感動してサードサードって言うんです
わかってるかと言いたいんですけど
もう間違ってても言っちゃうと
みんな一斉にサードサードって言うんです
決まりで 言葉聞いただけありがたいと
それをうるさいんだから
私は説法するときは全然そういう感動のフレーズは全部取り消し使わない
でもこちらではかなり疲れますよ
このもう決まってる言葉使わないで
あえてそこら辺にある子供たち使ってる言葉で喋らなくちゃいけないんだから
結構疲れますけど 感動しちゃうんだからね
聞くこともしないで この
このスリランカで一応お勤めなんか
このすごい伝統的にやっているあるお坊さんがすごく節を入れて
このエコウの文の場合はシンハラ語で
この功徳は道と果と涅槃のためになるようにと
それはシンハラ語で という調子で言うんですよ
えらいもう力入れてマーガとパラとニルバーナというね
これは向こうの人々は感動するんだけど
道果涅槃と言ったっても
あまり日本語ではそんなに耳障りのいい言葉にはならないんです
この貪瞋痴ではなくて
心穏やかになる歌というか
このイントネーションというかね
それはあるんですよ これは声明とできてあってね
日本にはそういう文化がないんだから
とにかく欲を引き出すという音楽と同じくね
だからこれからでも考えて作らないと
この何とか節をね 貪瞋痴を抑えて心が落ち着いてくる
今言ったマーガ・パラ・ニルバーナという
そのシンハラ語の読み方なんかは結構心落ち着くんですよ
例えば生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにというのは
向こうの言葉で言えばという調子で言うんです
だからなんとなくこの心が落ち着いて
その気持ちになる でもそれも調子っていうのはそれぞれの言語の特別なものなんですよ
だからシンハラ語のイントネーションで日本語を言ったっても気持ち悪いだけなんです
日本語のイントネーションでパーリ語を喋ると
私もすごいえらい気持ち悪くなっちゃう
だからそれぞれの言語が自分のスタイルというのがありますから
日本語でも作らなくちゃいけないんです
これから 発明しなくちゃいけないんです
それで話戻りますけど
アッパマーダはマーガであって
道である 方法ですね 涅槃はパラ
結果なんですね 注釈書でパダンというーパダというのは道という風に書いてます
でもう一度元の これでアッパマーダというものは不放逸ということ
アマタパダ アマタは涅槃の道であるという意味になるんですね
いわゆる涅槃の方法である
涅槃を実践する方法である
これ読んでみてください
パマドマチナ イェーパマッターナミーヤンティ
イェーパマッターヤタマター
何てそうだったっけ これでアッパマッターっていうのは人々のこと
不放逸の人々はナミーヤンティ
死なないぞと 死なないぞということは涅槃を得ているんだよという意味なんですね
次に出てくる疑問は なんで涅槃に不死
死なないという言葉を使ってますかと
実は死ぬのに お釈迦様亡くなったのに
だからお釈迦様に入れ替えてみれば
お釈迦様がやっぱり自分がアッパマーだから死なないぞということを言っていましたけど
でも亡くなっているんですけどね
だからなんで明らかにそういうことを明らかにわかってわかりきっていることは言ってるんですかね
不死なるものだと 不放逸な人々は死なんぞと
なんで言ってるんですか？ はい
はい  私もここ一番よく何だろうなと思ったんですけど
お釈迦様がおっしゃることは
大きく分けて心と肉体のことでいえば
心のことを言っているんだろうと
肉体についてはもう死ぬのは当たり前で
当たり前のことなんですけども
心について言ってれば
心は瞬間ですから 瞬間の時って生きているかどうかっていう問題で
瞬間の時生きてればもうそれは死んでないっていうことですから
もうそのままその死んでないと
死ぬことはないと言ってもいいのかなっていうふうに思ったんですね
それで逆に放逸の人っていうのは
その瞬間にはもう心はもう死んだと同じというか
正気じゃないわけですから
死んでるんだということだというふうに一応は理解したんですけど
うん もうちょっとあります
不死という言葉は 2つの原因でこの言葉使ってます
一つは常識で考えると
宗教の世界では宗教は何であろうとも
この理想とする境地に不死というんです
これはヒンドゥ教であろうか
キリスト教であろうか
イスラーム教であろうか
もっとすごい優れてる日本のあらゆる新興宗教であろうか
で もう理想とする境地は不死というんですね
そこは永遠たりと それでお釈迦様はそのその意味だけ取る
いわゆるこの言語学的に語る時は理想の境地に使う言語は何ですかと
例えば 人々は夜寝て最初に食べる
それに使う言語何ですか？と
何ですか 朝ごはんでしょ
朝ごはんか朝食はなんとかですね
それを取って だから朝食と言えば
ただ寝て起きて最初に食べる食べ物という意味で取るんです
それでお釈迦様は別な食べ物を推薦してるかもしれません
朝起きてこんなもうご飯やらパンやら食うなよと
その代わりにこういうもうジュースとかね
こういう葉っぱとかね
こういうものを食べなさいと言ってるかもしれません
しかし朝食なんですね
そうやってこの言語学から人間努力して至るべき境地
究極的な境地に人間使ってる言葉
何なのかと見たところで
24時間みんな使っている言葉っていうのは不死という言葉なんです
だからそれ使わせないんです
それは一つの理由なんです
誰でも使っている言葉
しかし みんな思っているように永遠に天国で何も変化なくいるぞという意味では使ってないんです
そんな面白くないというか
えらい苦しいんじゃないかと
それだったら 何の終わりもない生き方と言えばね
たまったもんじゃないんです
で 成り立たないしね それは置いておいてね
それで使ってます もう一つは
生きるということは瞬間瞬間変化することなんですね
それがものすごく疲れる
何をしても何をしても
すぐすぐすぐもう変わってしまう
もうやりきれないんですよ
だから生きるっていうことは苦しみにことにしているんですよ
次から次 次から次へ ノンノンストップで
ずっと変化する この変化っていうのは良い方向だったらありがたいんですが
残念なことにそうじゃないんですよ
例えば 赤ちゃんが毎日みるみるうちに変化するでしょ
でもどちらかというと
あの どんどん我々から見れば
まあ喋り出しちゃう 最初に何とか変な言葉なんですけど
親が勝手に解釈するんだから
ママと言ったんだよとかね
パパと言ったんだよとかね
別にそう言ってないんですけどね
で そういうふうなことで親がものすごく喜んじゃう
で やっと立ったと これもうものすごい大変な出来事で
ビデオを撮るは 写真撮るはもう大変なことで
それでそれ短い間の変化はまあみんな喜びますけど
それからどんどん他の方向に変化するんですね
好ましくない方向へ それで自分の体にしても
毎瞬間 毎瞬間 年を取るという
衰えるという方向へ行くんです
これから元気になるぞということは絶対あり得ないんです
あまりにもひどいもんだから
それは見ようと聞こうと考えようともしないんですね
考えちゃうとひどすぎなんですよ
自分の明日考えちゃうと真っ暗なんです
正しく考えるならば だから誰も考えません
いつか明日あるさと という全くデタラメ言うんです
明日はあるかもしれませんだけど
私いて真っ暗だよ それは
今日よりは明日幸福ということはないんです
明日は 1日年取っているんです
心臓もかなり疲れているんです
今日よりは 細胞もかなり派手派手にダメージを受けているんですね
ということだから この変化っていうのは
もう結局はあまりそうなってほしくないものなんですね
で ずっと物事変化する
変わりなく変化する 何をやってもキリがない
朝ごはん作って食べたんだから
まあこれでいいんじゃないかと
放っておく 放っとすることできないんですよ
また次に昼も作らなくちゃ
じゃあ昼も食べたんだから
まあいいや もうこれではないんですよ
どこまででも どこまででもやらなくちゃいけない
いつ休めるかというとないんです
休めないんですね それでこの瞬間瞬間物事を変化するだけではなくて
二度とリピートできんように消え去っていくんです
全て これ人間がただ考えてないだけ
人間の素晴らしいところっていうのは
事実だったら 絶対真っ向から逆らってやるぞと
嘘だったら徹底的に信じてやるぞという生き方は全ての人間やっているんです
だからニュースにしろ何にしろ流しているのは嘘だったらみんなもう聞いたり覚えたりもします
伝えたりもします 本当のことだったらケロッと忘れちゃう
そういう風に我々は何とかこの苦しみをごまかしてるんです
あれごまかして問題解決しないんだから
がん患者に告 あの宣告しないような感じで
宣告しなかったっていう
宣告というんですか 告知しないと
告知しなかったんだから
そいつは治りますかね
だから告知しなかったんだからといって何の意味もないんです
その人は知らないんだから
もうあえて生活をいろいろいい加減に生きていて
もっと一年で死ぬ人は半年死ぬ可能性もあります
だから告知しない主義はブッダは取ってないんですね
告知すると 堂々とありのまま
それでみんなもう怯えたり
怯えますよと 怖がる 怖がりますよと
嫌になる 嫌がりますよと
だから告知するんだよと
人間が嫌がる 怯える 震える
でもこれ事実ですからと
それで認めて初めて人間が
では私はどうすればいいかという問題が出てくるんです
そこで本人が苦しみのことを聞いて
命の儚いことを聞いて
無意味であるということを聞いて
みんなにまんまと騙されているんだと
子供にも騙されているんだ
奥さんにも騙されているんだと
あんた馬鹿見てるだけやと
ということを言ったところで
もう今まですごくありがたいと思っていた価値観が全部なくなっちゃって
ではこれから私はどうすればいいかという
そういう心境に陥るんですよ
それでお釈迦様はアッパマーデの方法を教えてあげる
そういうことで また二番目の説明は終わってないんです
それで瞬間瞬間変化するということは
瞬間瞬間死ぬということなんです
死ぬということは別れる
なくなるということでしょ
別れる なくなると楽しくないんです
だから私は瞬間瞬間 私たちはその苦しみを味わっているんです
死ぬのは苦しみ 愛する人々は出て行っちゃうわ
フラれるわ 嫌な人がもう自分では憎い
好みはタイプでもなんでもない人が一生懸命付き合ってくれ
友達になってくれと しつこく
もうもうもうしつこく頑張っているわ
そうすると自分の楽しみが死んでしまうんですよ
そういうふうに 瞬間瞬間
我々は死を経験しているんです
限りなく死んでるんです
いくら死んでも 次の瞬間また死ななくちゃいけない
次の瞬間また死ななくちゃいけない
この死の苦 死の連続なんです
生きるということは だから
あまりいい気分にはならないんです
これ大変だ大変だとわかると
この死ぬっていうこと楽しみになっちゃうんです
大変ですぐ終わりますから
ということで 何てことない
すぐ終わりますよと だから無常を知った人がえらいリラックスする
そんなに気にするもんかと
ということにリラックスできるし
それでこの瞬間瞬間の死っていうものはとにかくあります
それからこの物事っていうのは変化ですから
もうここを変化するものにはストップないんだから
ノンストップで変化だからね
人の体が壊れても 生命としてまたノンストップで変化し続くんでしょう
それでこの世の中でこの物理的な死
俗世間の死もあるでしょ
この俗世間的な死でも我々は悲しいんですからね
好きな人々から永久的に別れなくちゃあかんし
そういう俗世間でいう死にしたっても
それで終わるわけじゃないんですね
ああ やっと死んでよかったと
例えば自分がすごい究極な苦しい状態で悪いことってのは
死ぬ時は究極的な悪い状態で死ぬんだからね
最高の幸せな状態で死ぬっていうことはありえないんです
体がもうこれ以上は動けないとエンスト状態で死ぬんですよ
だからエンスト状態になるまではガタガタガタガタ動かしているんだから
結構苦しいんですよ 体が
はい  我々の実体というものは
こと変容して 常に死んでいく
それが我々の執着とか我執というものがなぜ滅んでいかない
なぜ滅んでいかない 我々はいつもその執着や我執の塊で生きてはいるんですよ
変化していくならば 我執や執着も刻一刻と死んでいっていいはず
なぜそれは生き残って
我々七十になっても八十になっても何も変化しないのか
それはどういう  我執も刻々と変化していくんですよ
だからただ我執という言葉を使うんだから変化しないように思うだけで
それも刻々と変化していきます
しかし どんな瞬間にも我執があるっていうことが問題なんですね
それはなぜかというと
今の瞬間なくなっちゃうでしょ
これ惜しいんですよ なくなってほしくないというふうに
もう自然的に生まれる
でもなくなっちゃう そうすると惜しかったのにという気持ちがそちらにあるんですね
次の瞬間現れるでしょ
力強く それにしがみつくんです
でもなくなる それでまた次の瞬間
またより力強くしがみつくんです
だから我執もそれなりに刻々と変化しますが
そうやって力強くなったり弱くなったり
例えば状況が悪いばっかしだったら
我執はからからに減るんですよ
こんな生き方っていうのはもううんざりだとかね
まあ死んだ方がマシだとかね
もう興味ないんだとか
その場合は我執はいくらか弱くなってるんですよ
なぜならば刻々変化するんだけど
どんな変化でも面白くない
しかし 我執がそれでもある
これが変わって別なものになってほしいと
そういうことだから 我執もずっと個々変化しつつ続けてしまう
それをそこにエネルギーを与えているのは自分なんだ
そのものがエネルギーですからね
外からエネルギー入るわけじゃないんですよ
今のエネルギーがなくなっちゃうと
また別に別な形になってしまうというね
それでもう一つあります
なんでこの我執が消えないかというと
我々は見ようとしないんですよ
無常ということは 例えば明日真っ暗と私は言ったでしょ
正直なところはそんな話聞きたくないでしょ
それなんです問題は  変化して一刻一刻というのが自然な状態なのに
我々はそれに逆らって不自然にそこへこう
そういうことなんです
不自然に変化しないんだぞと
でもあなた死ぬと言っても天国なんかあるんだよと
人間もうみんな愚痴なんですね
そうそう それ仏教が言ってるところなのよ
全くの無知で もう全くの逆さまだよと
考え方を逆に変えてみなさいと
その瞬間で我執が消えるんです
あ なんだと こんなもんかと
そこで無常だから良かったと
その時はやっと発注できるんですよ
今まで無常は嫌嫌嫌と思ってるでしょうね
悟りに至ったら やっぱり無常だから良かったと
何も実体が無いんだから良かったと
気にすることなんもないんだぞと
そこですごくリラックスできて安らぎを感じる
そこまで人間っていうのは全く逆さまに物事を見ている
ということで 我執がずっと生まれつつですね
はい よろしいですか では
話に戻ります それで この俗世間でいう死の後でも
また心が また体を構成したりして
また現れちゃう 例えばやっとガンで一年二年苦しんで死んだ人でも
あ これで終わったっていうことじゃないんですよ
また体が現れちゃうと
次にどんなひどい目にあうかわからないんですよ
ね 例えばニワトリにでもなってみてください
太陽の光を見る権利がなくなっちゃうんですね
豚にでもなってみてください
もう殺されて食べるわけでは自由だから
海の魚になってみたって
もうトローラーでもう根こそぎにとってしまって
もう海の魚が今なくなってるみたいでしょ
だからもうひどい目にあう
どこに生まれ変わったっても
そういうことだから アッパマーでの人はずっと限りなく死を経験しなくちゃいけない
そこで涅槃って何なのかというと
心が死なない状態になるんだという意味じゃないんです
この辺は人間には理解できない
心っていうのは体よりも強烈に瞬間瞬間瞬間変化することなんです
だからこれでどうなるかって
それ以上は言葉ありませんと
では 涅槃になったらどうなるかと
それ以上もう終わりと
考えないで 考えるなかれと
経験してみなさいと 言葉がないんだと
だから想像もできない
涅槃ってもしかするとこんなもんではないかと
全くの想像もできない
考えることもできない
これ天国とは違うんです
例えば 聖書というテキスト集たくさんありますからね
その中で天国の話あるでしょ
よくよく読んでみてください
ただ 人間の世界を語っているだけ
天国のことを語ってるわけないんです
だからもう語れないんですよ
経験ないものは 別にそういう天国があるっていうことを僕は認めませんですけど
あの涅槃って何なのかといえば
もう苦しみが終わりましたと
無常無常という心は無常で
体は無常で そういう状況もそれで終了しましたと
それで不死なんです 無常も終了しましたと
だから涅槃の説明は お釈迦様のこの無常の苦しみの終了
無常の終了という風にしか説明できんと
感情から見れば この我執やら渇愛やら怒りやらね
そちらの完全たる終了やと
だから終了 終了という言葉でしか説明しない
そういうことだから 涅槃は不死と言うんです
2番目の定義は結構難しいんです
だから一般の人々に輪廻転生して死んじゃうでしょ
いつでも それがなくなるんだよと
というふうな単純にしているんです
生まれないから死なない
とも言えますけど そう言っちゃって
まただったら嫌ですよと言うんですよ
生まれもないんだからと
注釈書でもしょうがないんだから
老病死も何もないというふうに解釈してますけどね
それは理屈的に考える人は言うんですけど
やっぱり聞いてるのは人間だからね
嫌がっちゃうんですね
でもお釈迦様その言葉を堂々使ってます
生まれもなく 老いることもなく
死ぬこともないところだよと
で 死ぬこともないところで言ったら
ああ ありがたいなと 生まれることもない
あらっていう なんだこれとまたわからなくなっちゃうんです
それで困りますから 仏教のこの逆さまに物事を見る人
困りますから では 苦しみがないと理解しなさいと
全くもないんだと 苦しみの完全な消滅だと理解しなさいと
いうと またネガティブマイナス論理でそうですかということになるんです
引き算でしか説明できないんですね
そういうことで涅槃に不死と呼ぶんです
それで番目で このエータンヴィセーサトーニャットはこのヴィセーサと
このペキュリアリティー
特色 特徴 これはどんな特徴特色ペキュリアリティーというと
このアッパマーダというこの言葉には
このとてつもない大変な機能がある
無常発見できる 一切の善はついてくる
我々悩んで文句文句言ってる
この我々の欠点やらね
全部もう見事に消えていく
知恵が完成していく 煩悩が消えてしまう
悟りを開けるというあまりにもすごい特徴なんですね
それを知恵ある人は理解すると理解して
やっぱりこれこそありがたくならなくちゃいけない
これに触れなくちゃいけない
いわゆる瞬間瞬間サティを実践することに触れなくてはいけないんです
これが趣味に趣味というんですか
趣味にしなくちゃいけないんです
あ これが楽しいと この楽しいという言葉はちょっと気をつけてください
このこの何て言いますか
日常生活で何かしらで楽しむということは
何か刺激があるということなんですね
刺激あることは苦しみなんですよ
この刺激がなく穏やかになる
それが楽ということなんで
楽しみというよりは この楽を楽しむわけじゃない
あ ややこしくないんだと
単純だと で サティに刺激がないと言ったっても
そう簡単じゃない サティこそ難しいんだから
このかなり脳には仕事があるんですよ
それで刺激がない分は億分で補っているんです
この知恵がそれで立ち上がってきますから
例えば瞬間瞬間実況中継サティ実践するでしょ
何の刺激もない 花が咲いているのに見える見えると言わなくちゃいけないし
鳥たちが綺麗に鳴いているのに
音と言わなくちゃなんでもないと思っちゃうでしょうね
そんなことじゃないんですよ
鳥が綺麗に鳴いているのに
音と言うと そちらに普段よりはすっごい努力なんです
すぐそこに陥ってしまって
あの鳥の声にという風になっちゃうでしょうね
綺麗やとかね それが僕はなんてバカかと
そうではなくて 耳にバンバン鳥のさえずり声が入っているのに
全く冷静で 音を音と それはずっと音が流れてくる
音と言うと この脳の中でこの感情的な刺激が生まれてないようにするということは
これものすごい仕事なんです
脳に対しては なかなかできるものじゃない
脳はもうできてるのは音が入ったらなんで綺麗ですかっていうことになるんです
そういう道ができてるんです
だからなんか昔テレビで娯楽番組とかイライラ棒というなんとかあったんですね
いろんなことをやらせて
もう百万円とか何とかとかね
誰も賞金獲得しないでしょ
だからそういう風にできてるんだからね
イライラ棒というものを持っていこうと思ったら
すぐ触れてしまって ブーブーと泣いちゃうんです
それで終わりと それで
ではゆっくり それで時間切れだと
それでまあ勝手にやれと言ったら
もうもうすぐもう音が鳴って
もうゲームオーバーになるのは普通でしょうし
だからパターンはそういう風にできている
しかし それに逆らって短い時間でイライラ棒は電気につなげないようにさーっと早く持っていくということは大変な仕事なんです
何の刺激もないんです
ただ落ち着いて手をさーっと速く持っていかなくちゃいけない
でも ものすごい力 労力
集中力が必要なんです
だからその人はすごいんですよ
あれで賞金取った人は本当にすごいんですよ
このサティもそんなもんじゃなくて
ものすごいもんなんです
声が入ってるのに音 音で処理してみる
痛みが出てくると まあ普段は足を伸ばしちゃいますけどね
すぐ体を変えますけど
プログラムはそういう風にできているんです
だから足が痛くなったら体を変えるっていうことはとても簡単です
痒くなったらサッと もう考えてもないんで
もう手が入って掻いてるんです
それがもう脳には何の刺激もない生き方なんです
だから別に刺激求める酒やら麻薬やら音楽やら踊りやら
いろんなところで刺激を求めていく
求めても脳は成長しない
プログラム変えないで同じプログラムで使ってるんだから
その場合はバカであればあるほど楽しめるんですよ
だから 俗世間の刺激を得るためにはバカでなきゃできないんです
頭が鋭い人にとっては
この最近の映画を見て全然面白くないと思いますよ
ただの部屋の隠れてコンピューターでやってる映像だから
昔の技術でああいう映画作っちゃうと
もうものすごく驚きますけど
全部もう手でいろんなことでやらなくちゃいけなかったでしょうに
今はもう人 千人でも移動させますけど
実際は三人ですね 使っている
人三人ぐらい使って そこでコンピューターでデータを取って
そこはもう倍 何とかもう反則させちゃって
もう千人にするとかに
だからこの それを知ってる人だったら別に面白いってことなくなっちゃう
本当のところは だからバカだったらすごいすごいとと楽しめると
音楽聴く時でも踊る時でも
やっぱりバカであればあるほどもう楽しめます
ということは 脳のプログラムは改良しないってことなんですね
そこでサティが面白くないと最初には思うのは当たり前なんです
ここで喜怒哀楽っていうのは
人間にとっては何よりもありがたいことではないかと
それを否定しちゃうとすごくつまらないのではないかと
落ち込んでしまうのではないかという文句はやってない人は最初は出す
それで私が言うのは とにかくものは試しだから試してみなさいと
[背景音楽]他の答えはないんですよ
いえ 違いますよと言っても意味がない
いえ 喜怒哀楽よりはすごい刺激があります
言ったってもこれ訳が違うんだから
そうすると本人が即席で得られる刺激で計算する
いわゆる元のプログラムで間違ってるプログラム
これもダメ ですから 物は試しだから試してみなさいということしか言えないんです
ですから 音が入ったら
なんて美しい鳥の声だなではなくて
そんなのは誰にでもできますからね
綺麗な声の動物の耳を向けるでしょうに
傾けるでしょうに あんなのはどうったことはない
ですから 音 音で処理しようとする
そうするとすごい脳がもう機能
機能というか もう働き出します
いまだかってやらなかった仕事だから
結構働かなくちゃいけないんですよ
この脳が働くということが本当は楽しみなんです
人間にとって 人間がこの決まってるちっぽけなこの子供用のプログラムで
例えばこの小学生一年生でもコンピューターのプログラムを教えるならば
何を教えるんですかね
何のアルゴリズムも何も教えられませんでしょう
だから なんとかかんとか一つ二つぐらいの教えるしかないんですね
でも小学生にはプログラム組むようなことは教えられませんし
キーボードもろくに打てませんし
だから大体お絵描きとかね
それぐらいにはしている
だからそういうプログラムを楽しむんじゃないんですよ
それも楽しいんですけど
それで脳が刺激を受けると
別の新しいプログラムでかなり楽しみを味わう
でもその質は違う このこちらでこのラマティという言葉
ラティというね ラマティという意味なんですけどね
で パモーダンティ パモーダンティっていうのはすごい喜ぶっていう意味なんですよ
満足して喜ぶっていう意味なんですね
ただの喜びじゃないんです
パモーダンティっていうのは満足するっていうこと
ということはかなり喜ぶっていうことでしょうね
普通は喜んだって満足はできんだから
この脳が動くことは楽しみということは
まず論理 あの論理的にでも理解してほしい
それで 1 秒足らず実況中継してみる
うまくいくとびっくりするほどその世界の楽しみが現れます
すっごい早い だから皆様方は 1 秒足らずの実況中継してやるぞというチャレンジしなくちゃいけない
これをやってないんですよ
だからみんなこのなんとかかんとか祈りながら
もうどうしようもないまま早く終わらないかという状態でやっている
そうならないんですよ
すっごく疲れていていたっても
ヴィパッサナー始めた瞬間で消えます
その時にもう消えてしまって
もうもう昨日っていうのは全く違う
時間はかかりません それにはこのサティはものすごく上手にプロらしく
やらなくちゃいけないです
そういうことだから この賢者は智慧のある人はこのアッパマーダを楽しむ
サティの実践を楽しむんだと
これこそ楽しみですから
それは賢者が喜びの特色を知っているんです
他は楽しめない それで涅槃を得られるという話なんです
えーと この智慧が楽しみということは
ひとつ例を言います 将棋なんかなさっていますかね
私はないんです わかりません
あれは難しくて でも日本の伝統的なスポーツだからね
将棋っていうのはただじーっと座ってるだけでしょう
ボーリングとは違うでしょ
では すごい長い間楽しむのはどっちですか？ボーリングですか？将棋ですかね
結局は将棋なんですよ
あれが智慧の勝負だから
まあプロは決まってる時間でね
さっさと手を動かさなくちゃいけないんですけど
普通の人にはその時間制限ないんだから
じっと手を組んで あれ三角形ですか？五角形ですかね
五角形のあの白い文字書いてるあれよく見ているでしょ
えっ？駒をね 絵があるわけでもないし
色あるわけでもないし
でも見ているでしょ あれ何が楽しいんですかね
楽しみが脳の中にあるんですよ
脳がむちゃくちゃむちゃくちゃぐちゃぐちゃ動いてるんだから
だからボーリングよりは楽しいと思いますよ
よりもゲートボールよりも何よりも
そういうわけで 本当にこの味わう
体で感じる楽しみっていうのは
まあ脳ですよ 脳最高です
そういうことで ヴィパッサナーこそこの将棋とは違う
これ一秒の勝負だから
一秒じゃないんですよ
まあちょっとやってみると
一秒っていうのは結構長く感じますよ
例えば心臓の動きに実況中継入れてみてください
結構早いんですよ その間
一秒に一回じゃないでしょ
心臓は で あるいは音と聴覚に実況中継してみてください
耳元で音が触れるということは感じられます
あ 触れたと じゃあ音 あ
これ聴覚よと どれほど早くやらなくちゃあかんか
だから一秒の勝負じゃないんですよ
そういうふうなことでできれば
もうこれが楽しみであるとわかるんです
まあ怠けるということではない
だいたいこの三つの芸の意味は
まあそれぐらいのものね
それが涅槃への道であるということで
で 話は終了したいと思っています
はい では とりあえずだいぶ時間を押しておりますので
これで  1個だけ ただの説明で方法とか道という説明があったんですけども
ダンマパダという時に法句経という風に我々は言ってますけど
法の道とか法の方法という風に読んでもよろしいのでしょうか
Verseというかフレーズという意味ですよ
法の何？ 道の方法  その道はダメですね
パダっていうのは言葉って意味で意味があります Word
フレーズ だから法句なんです
その場合は方法とか道という訳はダメなんですか
うん  それ以外に境地とか場所というそういう意味もあるんですか
どれもそうか  その場その場で適当な訳をつけるしかないという
境地 場所 ステークというね
ステークな場所 境地ということですね
シッカパダの時は学説とか
え？ シッカパダ  シッカパダというのはこのフレーズですよ
この項目  フレーズ 法律の項目というのは法律のいろいろ条文があるでしょ
一条二条三条とか その場合は条ということなんです
その場合はフレーズという言葉で取ってます
パダは一応足という意味ですよ
足 足の あの 足跡というか
歩というかね 歩く  そうしますとパダというあの A のバー
それは足 フットだけである
パダは パダも使いますよ
足跡ではなくて このストライドという英語の言葉ありますね
足を上げて一つ持っていく
前に それがパダなんです
ストライドは日本語になっちゃうと何でしょうかね
歩を運ぶ  歩を運ぶ うん
そうですね 運ぶということですね
歩というね  一歩二歩という
それはあのパダなんです
だから複数の意味に使うんです
よろしいでしょうか はいはい
あの不放逸 不放逸っていうのは仏教用語でまあ決まったあれなんですけど
それが一般に理解しやすいとした場合ですね
あの怠けないという言葉もありますけど
正気っていう あの狂ってないっていう意味で正しい正気っていうような意味に何かお話を聞いてると近いかなみたいにも思ったんですけど
違いますか？やっぱしちょっと
そういう言葉とは  だからね
いきなりそういう風に訳しちゃうと
またいろいろ文句言われるんですね
そういう問題なんですよ
この訳っていうのは ブッダの言葉はね
これはもう難しいんです
別に意味が間違ってるわけじゃないんです
うん 一応アッパマーダ
パマーダぐらいはパーリ語で覚えた方がいいと思いますよ
これはもう知らなきゃ何やってる感じで
それぐらいは知っておけって
これはもう基本的な言葉なんです
アッパマーダで始めてアッパマーダで仏教終わるんだからね
だからまあ 瞬間瞬間に気づいていることっていう
実践という場合はそれでヴィパッサナーっていうことになったし
一般的に言えばそのに目覚めている状態ということにもなっちゃうし
だから狂ってないってことでもいいんですけどね
いろんな言葉では語れる
はい あれアッパマーダっていうのはその動だから踏ん張ってやるもんで
ニッパナーっていうのはもう終わっとること
ん？ ニッパナーはアナーだからもうもう踏ん張ってやる必要はないっていうことになるわけですね
なにが  アッパマーダは踏ん張ってやることですね
ちょっと意味はちょっとそれじゃない
えっと だからアッパマーダっていうのは
その自分の心でこう何かやろうやろうと思って
グーッと一生懸命やってやっていくので
その結果っていうのは踏ん張ってやることではないんですよね
俺でも何なんかやってるか読み取れない
だからその  間違ってるところ説明します
アッパマーダはわかってないんです
アッパマーダは瞬間に気づくことなんです
そこであんた聞くべきなのは
瞬間に気づくことはどういう風にやれば
どれぐらい力入れればいいかっていうことなんです
それはその人は踏ん張らないとできないんだったら踏ん張らなきゃあかんでしょ
踏ん張らなくても瞬間瞬間に気づく人は踏ん張る必要はないんです
要は瞬間に気づくっていうことなんです
だから瞬間に気づくためには生半可でできんだから頑張るんだ
頑張る だから精進努力っていうのは小さな禅で
それがついてくるっていう話なんです
だから怠け者でもサティの実践を始めたらたちまち怠けが消えてしまうんです
そういうふうに理解した方が理解しやすい
アッパマーダは瞬間に気づくこと
では 私にできるかないかと
私の性格から見ればね
えらい頑張らなきゃできんと思ったらえらい頑張るしかないんです
その人には あ 私にだったらこれ楽チンでできるんだぞと思ったら楽チンでいいんです
要は瞬間瞬間に気づくということなんです
だから 仕事をしながらできる人は仕事をしながらやる
やっぱり私ような連中にはね
仕事をしながらこれ無理やと思ったら仕事辞めなくちゃいけないということで
まあやっぱり出家しなきゃできるわけないと思ったら出家するしかないんです
そういうのは決して別に推薦してないんです
仏教は 必ず出家しなさいとか
そのその人は自分の性格に合わせて態度を取るだけのことで
だからお釈迦様の時代で出家して悟った人もいて
出家しないで悟る人もいる
それはただ性格の問題だけです
お釈迦様はどちらが偉いということか
質問はもう捨てる どちらが偉いと聞くもんじゃないよと
どちらが結果出すと聞けと
結果出す人は 在家であろうが出家であろうが偉いんだよと
結果出さんバカは たとえ出家で百年いたってもバカやと
そういう風に定義するんであって
だから あの この 何て言いますか
付け加えるものは何かというと
その個人個人が考えればいいんですね
サティを実践するために
俗世間のことについては
精神的な異常現象を起こすといわれる病気になっちゃってね
仕事をするというか 舌を噛んで歯を噛んで
もうガリガリ神経で踏ん張ってやるとかね
これで体も心も全部ガタガタ壊れるとかね
そういうのは まあ俗世間で狂ってるんだからあるんであって
それはサティではありません
そういう人々は怠け者なんです
アッパマーダ 怠けで訳する場合は
放逸なんです たとえ神経すり減らして仕事をしていても
放逸そのものなんです
瞬間のこと知ってる人にとっては
そんな大したことじゃないんですよ
仕事は 仕事でもうヒステリー起こしたと
家事子育てにヒステリーを起こしたというのは
もう怠け者ということなんです
あの奥さんがすごい頑張りすぎてヒステリー起こすのは冗談じゃない
あれは頑張らなかったんだからなんです
家事で子育てでヒステリーを起こしたというと
ですから 瞬間瞬間の出来事を見てちゃんと行動する人にとっては
踏ん張るという言葉ももう成り立たないんですよ
なぜならば瞬間のことというのは至極簡単です
それをわからない人々は
俗世間ではいろいろトラブルは起こしてます
だからいつでもその自分の俗世間の態度で
その立場でその角度で見るのでは見られないんだ
仏教は だからもう一応これがやってみるということで
全部解決します 世俗の問題っていうのはね
だから円と億の例で考えちゃえばね
これだと思います このサティの意味をね
ちゃんとしっかりしない
それはこの瞬間に気づく
それは変えません その意味は
踏ん張るか何か勝手にしなさいと
こちらに必要なのは瞬間に気づくこと
じゃあ涅槃の状態というのもアッパマーダはあるということですね
当然のことながら  まあアッパマーダの至るべき結果ですよ
涅槃は アッパマーダは道で涅槃は悟りで結果でしょ
うん  有難うございました